so i want to take a second and look at  some egregious but also unintentionally  hilarious police misconduct  all right so the policeman enters the  garage  and then he just slams it into the car  slams it again  just  yeah it goes without saying this is  entirely improper but i do want to  highlight  a hilarious comment on twitter from  brian hamilton who highlights a kind of  passive  pro-police speech you often hear  describing conduct like this  a car was damaged today in an officer  involved door slamming  the car's manufacturer says it was a  good car but the carfax shows a more  complicated past  yeah even when there's videos sometimes  people have to both sides things  even when one of those things is a car  probably